this video is made possible by
Skillshare home to over 17,000 classes
that could help you learn a new life
skill be one of the first 500 to sign up
using the link below and get a two month
free trial with Skillshare judging by
the news and the state of world affairs
it's pretty easy to see why some people
think we may be nearing the end of the
world 10th political relations deep
societal divides rampant terrorist
activity and at least a handful of world
powers with access to huge numbers of
nuclear weapons does not bode well for
the future of humanity of course the
Cold War was as close as the world has
gotten to Armageddon and if we avoided
that perhaps we're not as doomed as we
might think that being said world
relations are about as frosty as they've
been since the Cold War especially with
the rumors of election meddling by the
Russian government and the bizarre
Twitter slap fight between Kim jong-un
and Donald Trump
so if society does collapse weather
thanks to nuclear fallout civil war or
some yet unknown Cataclysm how can we
make sure we're prepared in this
scenario we're going to assume that the
electrical grid has gone down which
means you won't be able to rely on your
electronics to survive however that
doesn't mean your cell phone will be
completely useless apps like backcountry
navigator for android and gaia gps for
iOS allow you to download maps to use
offline so even if you can't get Wi-Fi
or cell service any more
you can still figure out where you're
going your cell phone battery won't last
forever so make sure you have an
external power bank and a solar charger
to keep it operational just to be safe
keep a paper map of your area in your
backpack in case your phone breaks or
gets lost depending on the type of
apocalypse we're dealing with it might
be safest for you to remain in your home
for a few days use this time to gather
little necessities things like
prescription drugs allergy pills contact
lenses and extra glasses matches and
lighters to start fires flashlights and
extra pair of shoes layers of clothing a
can opener a multi-tool duct tape
paracord the list goes on and on
basically you need to grab everything
you can easily carry that will keep
tasks simple the most important things
you can gather from your home are things
you can put in a first-aid kit if you
don't have a pre-made one hydrogen
peroxide neosporin painkillers gauze
bandages tweezers and scissors an EpiPen
if you have one anything that could stop
a potential infection blood loss or
other medical emergency pack everything
you've gathered into the biggest
backpack you have
a camping or military bag works best
since they tend to have a large capacity
and lots of pockets but make do with
what you have have everything packed and
ready to leave at a moment's notice if
the grid is down then the only way
you'll be able to gather news from the
outside world is by using a radio having
a hand-cranked portable radio available
could be the difference between knowing
critical information and sitting in the
dark hoping for the best when you're
eventually forced to leave your home and
search for supplies you'll need a way to
collect safe drinking water there are a
few ways to do this first you can start
a fire and boil the water this should
clean it of most impurities but it does
take a while
second you can use a water purifier one
of the smallest and lightest options is
the LifeStraw it functions just like a
straw filtering water as it passes
through for larger groups there's also
the LifeStraw family which is a bigger
purifier you could set up at your
campsites but still small enough to
carry in a backpack finally if the
apocalypse you are dealing with is
caused by a virus you'll have to be very
careful with your drinking water for a
situation like that you'll want
something like the MSR Guardian filter
it does everything the LifeStraw
products do but it also filters out
viruses meaning you won't have to worry
about becoming a zombie after drinking
from that pond you found when you
eventually run out of canned and
dehydrated food you'll have to forage
and hunt to survive in the short term
and probably learn to farm if society
has truly crumbled beyond repair if
you're near a large body of water fish
are a nutritious and plentiful source of
food opt for a net instead of a fishing
rod to catch as many fish as you can in
a shorter amount of time
Nets also make decent traps for small
game and unwanted visitors for hunting
you have several options
first there's the bow quieter than
firearms a bow will let you hunt without
giving away your location to nearby
scavengers and makes a valuable ranged
weapon if they do find you on the other
hand bows do require more skill to use
effectively when hunting large game a
lot of people aren't comfortable
carrying a gun around or even owning one
but when the world falls apart and you
need a tool to protect yourself and your
loved ones from wild animals and in a
worst case scenario hostile humans it's
probably better to have one if you don't
have a rifle and you're an American
you're in luck because they're
ridiculously easy to buy especially if
you live somewhere like Texas that has
frequent gun shows this is a Mosin
Nagant a World War 2 era Russian
bolt-action rifle that was the most
widely produced gun in the world
until it was dethroned by the ak-47 that
means they can be had for next to
nothing and are available without a
license to just about anyone 18 or older
this is about 400 rounds of surplus
World War two steel core ammunition the
gun and the ammo together can easily be
found for about 200 to 300 dollars at
any decently sized gun show the only
things to consider when hunting with
this type of weapon and ammo is that
it's very loud and there might not be
anything left of the animal if it's
small like a rabbit so you might want to
use something like a slingshot to hunt
small game if you really don't want to
be put into a situation where you could
injure or kill another human being but
still want to scare people off at a
distance keep the gun unloaded or remove
the bolt and leave it in another bag
unless you intend to use it plants can
make a welcome addition to your diet but
many plants are toxic to humans so make
sure you have a hand guide to help you
determine what's edible and what's not
the last big consideration for surviving
the apocalypse is finding and
maintaining a good shelter tall highway
overpasses or bridges make for great
defensible locations if you can
barricade or destroy the ends you'll
just need a way to get down and hunt for
supplies large boats crewed by people
you trust could be another good option
if you have access to enough fuel to
last at least several weeks you could
sail out into deep water to isolate
yourself for most survivors but if
pirates come knocking you'll have to be
prepared to fight them off or give them
what they want two more options include
small uninhabited islands and offshore
oil rigs an island would be ideal for
survivors who hope to set up a permanent
settlement complete with small farms to
grow food on the other hand if you have
the supplies to last you a while and can
gain access to an oil rig
you've got possibly the best defensive
shelter you can find a pre-made metal
fortress raised high above the ocean
makes for an excellent base of
operations just make sure you have a
radio to know when it's safe to return
to dry land last but not least don't
discount the tried-and-true off-the-grid
cabin in the woods the United States
still has huge expanses of forests and
protected national parks which makes for
prime real estate for the experienced
woodsman if you have hunting and farming
know-how and can fashion a shelter out
in the middle of the woods then this
simple option could be your best bet
you'll have easy access to food in the
form of wild game and plants water from
streams plenty of material to build a
shelter and tools or weapons and enough
uninhabited land that you'll likely
never encounter another survivor as
scary as a post-apocalyptic world sounds
the good news is we're not
there yet and we may never be we have
the time to prepare and put together an
emergency kit just in case thanks to the
Internet there's a huge amount of
knowledge to be gained from experts in
the arts of hunting farming tracking and
general survival all it takes is a
little diligence to learn and prepare
for the worst best case scenario you
never have to use your newfound
knowledge and you get a bunch of useful
camping gear out of it
worst case scenario you'll be ready
while we're talking about learning a
great place to learn something new is
skill share as you all know I'm always
trying to improve my videos without
compromising the fun simple style we all
know and love to do that I'm taking a
class to polish my editing skills with
skill share learning by trial and error
is great but when you really want to
fast track your learning organize
classes are the way to go skill share is
an online learning community for
creators featuring over 17,000 classes
and video editing animation graphic
design film production and more anyone
can take a class try a project or even
teach a class themselves Premium
Membership begins around ten bucks a
month for unlimited access to everything
as a little thank you for watching my
videos skill share is offering a two
month free trial to the first 500 people
who sign up using the link below you can
use those two months to learn an awesome
new skill that you can use to market
yourself create a business or even start
a YouTube channel like I did there's no
better time than now to take that first
step towards learning that skill you've
always dreamed of having and since it's
completely free to try you have nothing
to lose be one of the first 500 to sign
up with the link below and start your 2
month free trial with skill share if you
enjoyed this video make sure to
subscribe to keep up to date with the
latest content and click the little bell
next to my channel name to join the
notification squad you can binge watch
the rest of my videos by clicking here
or if you're done learning for the day
come watch me play video games very
poorly on my new gaming channel thanks
for watching and I'll see you in the
next video